welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and even though what if
is a show of different universes
different timelines and different
realities they reveal so many timeline
implications for our MCU Universe in 616
the heroes in what if make decisions
that Branch off in a different direction
from the sacred timeline delivering
different outcomes but before those
sliding door moments happen we are
treated to some interesting timeline
implications that happened prior to
their stories popping off remember that
Marvel considers the what if stories to
be Canon even if they take place in a
different Universe in this video I'm
going to point out some of those facts
that are likely true in the sacred 616
timeline like confirming frigo wasn't
hell's mother so who the hell was or the
fact that Tony and Bruce created a Hulk
serum before the age of Ultron or that
Odin knew all about the 10 rings and by
the end of this video I'll even point
out something huge that ties this series
to one of Marvel's most successful
properties and possibly has even bigger
implications for the upcoming Secret
Wars and if you have not had a chance
already be sure to check out the
breakdowns of each and every episode of
what if season two on the new Rockstar
Channel Eric Voss and I and a full
Village team comb through each and every
animated bit bit of the episodes to
point out the details you might have
missed and explain how these what if
stories connect to the larger MCU and
one more thing please support our
Channel further by checking out nerd
rot. shop where you can grab some what
if inspired merch including our sakar
cart and the queen of chaos shirt
featuring the medieval Scarlet which
it's a great way to support the channel
and get yourself a perfect gift you
didn't get over the holidays check out
all the awesome options at nerd riot.
shop um I don't know if this shirt's
still here but this one's my
favorite all right let's get into it
while these episodes of wood if present
alternate realities and time line to the
MCU sacred 616 timeline there are events
in these episodes before those fateful
Whata if moments that provide insight
and knowledge into the MCU sacred
timeline that we did not know before
starting in episode one what if nebula
joined the Nova core we learned that
xandar has a world mind in the comics
the xandarian world mind is basically
like the supercomputer of all
supercomputers and holds all the
knowledge of the Nova force xandar and
everything in and around it the Nova
core was initially created to protect
xandar and the xandarian world mind no
matter what so this clearly is our
Mainframe in the first episode of what
if which further proposes that there was
a world M on xandar in our 616 Universe
we just didn't know about the Nova cor
wasn't powered by the worldmind in MCU
and we never saw the xandarian world
mine at play but we know in the MCU just
because we haven't seen it doesn't mean
it's not there but knowing the xandarian
world M existed in the comics and
existed in a timeline of what if it's
likely a version of the world mine or
the Mainframe or whatever we want to
call it exists in our universe as well
like I said earlier what if works like
the branching of timelines even a watu
mentions in your Universe this happened
but a turn for the worst happened here
for our here so he's already alluding to
our path starting identical they just
kind of strayed at one point and if the
cre had the Supreme intelligence we're
already like halfway there in the MCU
it's possible we see some sort of events
from the Marvels that happens to xandar
after Thanos destroyed the planet like
they'll lose everything oh God in
episode two we learned to chaka's Father
King AI donated to Howard Stark the
vibranium from the original Shield we
saw Howard making in Captain America the
First Avenger which is wild because we
didn't know how he got it we also
learned in the 1602 episode that the
king of w gave Thor a vibranium sword
called the Alla as a coronation gift so
the wakandans of 616 were always
watching these world events happen and
never intervening and like the 40s
during World War II and in the year
16002 and like we all know what was
happening in Africa around 1602 we
already know like what kilmonger was
saying in the first Black Panther movie
but we're really like witnessing wakanda
give King Thor a vibranium sword in 1602
while the Dutch slave trade was just
getting started and I know what you're
going to say I know what you're going to
say it's like Jessica technically the
slaves were here and wakanda was here
you're acting like wakanda wasn't so
Advanced they couldn't just peek out of
their shield and be like Oh our brothers
are being taken away they they clearly
didn't help you guys they didn't want to
and I guess during the events of World
War II wakanda saw what was going on and
rather than intervene they figured
giving Howard Stark a little vibranium
would just fix things right up I got
love for my people but wakanda was very
shady at first now that's not news to us
we know the history of wakanda they only
intervene when they're being affected
but it's clear that before we really
knew wakanda they were sharing samples
of vibranium with a lot of people which
in every possible way will bite them in
the ass in the future we saw when Mor
people can do with like similar
resources we know there are pieces of it
in our equipment and people searching
the oceans for it but there are also
people who simply already own it thanks
to a gift from a hidden Kingdom that
created Shields or other weapons from it
God
wakanda wakanda in episode three of what
if happy Hogan Saved Christmas Darcy
worked as an intern for Stark Industries
and knew happy Hogan we also learned
that Tony Stark and Bruce Banner created
a semi valuable Hulk anti- serum as far
back as December 2014 so that's like
right after the events of Captain
America winner soldier project insight
and Iron Man 3 and a few months before
the age of Ultron Tony making the serum
is still plausible and expected in 616
as Tony built Bruce a lab in Mexico
where Banner worked on himself
integrating the Hulk Banner identities
in the first Avengers movie Tony was so
interested in the mechanics of Hulk
telling him it was even like a blessing
that he had this curse so it's not
surprising as a friend and as like a
colleague he was trying to solve Hulk's
anger issues and also being the nosy
genius that he is Tony's been messing
around with Banner's blood seeing if he
can make him the Hulk without the uh
anger management issues was he
successful uh you know it's a process
Darcy meeting happy at her internship
for Tony Stark is also weird but also
let's go down Darcy's timeline really
quick first the student poly side to
Eric's intern and assistant to Jane
Foster in 2011 during this time Shield
showed up and started commandeering all
of Jane's research because Thor was seen
as a threat then later Nick Fury then
gets Eric involved with the tesser ACT
later in Thor dark World Jane and Darcy
fight about Shield crawling up their ass
again as they normally do then Darcy
returned to her school to graduate with
her doctor in astrophysics in 2013
around this time Darcy could have been
an intern for Tony Stark as she's a jack
of all trades and has been fluctuating
in the MCU between an intern and having
an intern then cooperating with Shield
then working for swore during the hex
view in 2023 additionally the second
iron Legion suit we see in this episode
of what if were made in 2015 and Justin
Hammer was sent to prison around spring
of 2010 so Darcy after college working
for Tony isn't that crazy as she went
off our radar between 20 13 and 2023 so
let's assume Darcy interning for Stark
and working under happy Hogan is canon
in 616 we've all had that bad habit
biting your fingernails drumming your
fingers ringing your hands you get the
idea Idol hands are the Devil's
Playground and all that start your new
year off- right by trying the good habit
with fume fume was made to help replace
your bad habits with good ones and you
can enjoy guilt-free it's an Innovative
award-winning device with no electronics
no vapor and no harmful chemicals oo
that's actually good for me got a lot of
chemicals in my life I live in LA fume
is completely natural and uses all
natural ingredients to give you a
delicious burst of flavored air I like
Maple pepper because it feels Regal like
I'm a monarch of a delicious bacon kdo
fum is also super fidgety which is
helpful for de-stressing while you break
your old habit each device has an
adjustable airflow dial and is designed
with movable parts and magnets as much
as I enjoyed the original model I got to
say the new Solano F might be my new
favorite it's made with a premium Walnut
barrel and an onyx coated mouth pizza
that's a little bit softer it feels
fancy like a million times fancier than
you know nine on my cuticles all the
time start the year off right with a
good habit by going to trif nume.com
neww rockstars and getting the journey
pack today fume is giving our audience
10% off when they use the code new
rockstars to help make starting the good
habit that much easier in episode four
what if Iron Man crashed into the grandm
Tony Stark winds up on sakar after
nuking the chitari while defending New
York during the events of the Battle of
New York in the 2012 Avengers film when
he arrives the Grand Master shows him
news footage of the Avengers defending
New York City and gives Tony the title
of metal Mojo man horrible name this
shows us the grandmas has been keeping
eyes on Earth's Mightiest Heroes from
the very beginning even if he pretends
to not know who they are so when Thor
arrived on sakar and Thor Ragnarok it's
safe to assume The Grandmaster knew
exactly who he was not only from keeping
an eye on the Avengers actions on Earth
but he's also the legendary as guardian
God The Grandmaster must have heard of
Odin's exploits at some point when The
Grandmaster first meets Thor he says
this here's what I want to
know who Are You The Grandmaster often
refers to Thor as the Lord of Thunder or
hey Sparkles which isn't as insulting as
something like Mr metal Mojo man but
still a way for the grandm to play aloof
and purposely mislabel his prisoners
with jobs who sometimes happen to be
Gods just to mess with their heads it's
a great way to keep them subserviant and
second guessing themselves the Grand
Master called Asgard Asgard Asgard the
man knows what he's doing he's heard of
Asgard we've all heard of Asgard it's
not Asgard in episode 5 what if Captain
Carter fought the Hydra stomper we
rehash some of the events of Captain
America Winter Soldier with Captain
Carter having a close relationship with
natas Romanov this is the universe where
Peggy is now the leader of the Avengers
and picking up from the post credit teas
in season one of what if Peggy is now
trying to track down her Steve who she
learns is still alive inside the Hydra
stomper armor much like Steve learn
Bucky was still alive in the MCU but
through the events of this episode we
learned from Steve that the Soviet Union
had constructed fake American cities to
train KGB spies and then the Red Room
took those cities over after the Soviet
Union fell the one we see in this
episode is in sovia which was likely
under the control of the the Soviet
Union at some point this fact is
probably also true in the MCU sacred
timeline and it's likely that the Winter
Soldier Red Guardian Yola Molina and
even Black Widow herself were trained in
one of these cities along with plenty of
other widows the test City we visit in
this episode even has a slight
resemblance to Mount Vernon Ohio where
the Red Guardian and Molina were
stationed with Natasha and yolen at the
beginning of the Black Widow film maybe
we'll see one of these cities again in
the live action maybe that's where
Taskmaster is currently hiding out with
the other cured widows until Val shows
up to recruit her for the Thunderbolts
and she goes I don't know where I am
where's my father that put a chip in my
neck I don't like what they did to
Taskmaster but I like Taskmaster as a
person episode seven of what if hel
found the 10 Rings gives us a lot of
interesting ancient history that we can
apply to the MCU sacred timeline
including the fact that Odin was a huge
[__] 1,500 years ago and still a
freaking [__] well to be fair and
Thor Ragnarok he wasn't really an
[__] he just died okay either way we
always kind of knew this one but this
episode really drives this fact home in
Thor Ragnarok we did get a little taste
of hel's backstory including that she
was ODed 's executioner and helped him
conquer the nine Realms and kill a lot a
lot of beans in each of those Realms his
chill old man phe wouldn't come until
much later but the fact that most Odin
banish their daughters to hell is one
thing but even this Odin banishes his
daughter to midgard to learn mercy and
when she does is like nah I'm going to
kill her anyway Odin is always a bad dad
in like any any any Universe he's in
this episode also gives us a little
history about those mysterious 10 rings
in shangi and the legend of the 10 Rings
we learn that when Wu found the 10 Rings
thousands of years ago but gives a
couple of reasons as to
[Music]
how however here The Watcher makes it
clear that they came from off Planet
saying this like the 10 rings that
fueled his power Shu and woo knew all
too well the most powerful forces on
Earth often come from Beyond as when wo
looks to the sky so just like hel's
Crown in this episode it's implied that
the 10 Rings crash to earth like a
meteorite and when Odin confronts Hela
and when we in this episode he remarks
that the 10 rings do not belong in A
Primitive hands showing us that he knows
exactly what the 10 rings are this
further drives home the point that they
are not cre technology but something
more ancient and powerful than that boss
even theorized in his breakdown that the
10 Rings might have been in Odin's vault
at some point pointing out that they
glow blue like the other Vault items
such as the Tesseract and The Cask of
ancient Winters perhaps at some point in
the MCU sacred timeline Odin might have
attempted to retrieve the 10 rings from
one woo and was just unsuccessful but in
this episode Hela confirms that frga is
not her mother and at this point in the
timeline she's actually only Odin's new
girlfriend so if frga was not hela's
mother who was if we look at the real
Norse mythology it gets a little
confusing their Hela or hell is actually
the daughter of Loki and this person a
gianti with a name that translates to
the one who brings grief or she who
offers sorrow and a Norse mythology
friend re the wolf is hel's sibling so
that doesn't actually shed any more
light on hela's mother in the MCU in
Marvel Comics Hela was created by Odin's
father who created a black and infinity
stone that transformed into a baby girl
that became Hela it's possible that
within the MCU we may someday learn that
Hela was also some magical creation or
possibly Odin had a previous Paramore
that spawned Hela and given hela's
status as the goddess of death maybe her
mother was even like death herself ew
did Odin run around with thanos's girl
finally and quite possibly the craziest
Revelation from this season of what if
is at the end of episode 9 what if
strange Supreme intervened after
defeating strange supreme or convincing
strange Supreme to defeat himself The
Watcher shows Captain cter the recreated
universe that now exists with Christine
Palmer alive and Steven strange never
having existed at all but while they are
chatting a butterfly with green and
purple and blue markings lands on a Wu's
finger The Watcher then takes Peggy to
Elle the exact same igel we saw at the
end of season two of Loki that contains
the god of stories at its Center and the
color of the Elle matches the color of
the butterfly this has a lot of crazy
implications Loki was able to send a
butterfly to whatever Universe The
Watcher and Captain Carter were in Loki
is currently in igel holding together
the timelines of 61 6 replacing the TVA
Loom that was doing a similar job this
would mean that his Elle is likely
somewhere adjacent to the 616 Universe
outside of space and time like the TVA
but Loki god of stories must have some
ability to see into the universes and
even manifest magic in those universes
hence the butterfly while Loki is only
physically holding together the 616
timelines his new found abilities must
give him the power to see beyond the 616
Universe additionally bringing Captain
Carter a character who can see and
interact with the Watcher on her own
terms to igel presumably to meet Loki
could be a setup for the events to come
in secret Wars perhaps Loki is putting
together his own team of Nexus be to
help end the incursions and save the 616
if the Watchers are unwilling to
interfere it could be that Loki his new
Watcher esque abilities is planning to
push them aside and recruit his own
Nexus beings to form an even stronger
Guardians of the Multiverse for the
impending Secret Wars to come we are
clearly bringing Peggy Carter into the
MCU again liveaction wise and I I don't
hate this idea I actually love the idea
that they're just like oh she's so
strong let's put her in let's throw her
in Loki's got it Loki's making a team
Peggy Carter is going to lead it my mind
is melting and that's it for me today be
sure to check out our full Whata if
breakdowns if you haven't already and
please support our growing Network by
checking out our merch options at nerd
rot. shop follow me at Lulu Clemens
follow new rockstars on all social
platforms and consider subscribing to
the break room as we get ready to talk
about some Echo next
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
so you can be notified when we have some
more new analysis to offer I'll see you
guys
later
hey
hey hey